very rarely is there the perfect man and
the perfect job and we see it in actors
and we see it and we certain certain
politicians and stuff here was a man who
was born to play that role as president
of the United States and was an
inspirational leader when the nation
really needed it at that point in time
Ronald Reagan was sort of the FDR the
the conservative FDR he started the
Saturday morning radio program and used
that voice to reassure people whenever
he needed the groundswell of support in
Congress to get a bill passed he would
go to the people and talk from the Oval
Office and say I need you to call your
congressmen and Senators and tell him
you support my project here that this is
for us and it's you know it's important
and and people believed him you know and
they and they loved him he would be
assassination affected him in a rather
profound way I think he became really
aware of his vulnerability and his very
narrow threat of that hold you up to
life and he felt according to my
readings that he survived for a reason
and the reason was to broker a peace
deal with the Russians to to make the
world a safer place and that was his
purpose and that's I think what he
devoted himself to I found it him very
heroic that he found a greater purpose
in his life when that critical moment
where he thought maybe he would die and
certainly a lot of people thought he was
going to die it gave him a stronger
purpose to come back and refocus his
presidency and his
life
you